si je dis pas jacadies
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
très heureux de vous recevoir
c'est vraiment merci
son prénom merci
[Rires]
qui croyait que c'était toi toi je sais
pas 1000 non non c'est fou ça vient du
prénom
là vous êtes à l'affiche donc de Jet 7 2
qui s'appelle people qui réalisait par
Fabien antoniante avec José Garcia rue
perthevrette Élie Semoun Rossi de Palma
Jean-Claude Brialy et qui sort le 19 mai
sur les écrans voilà alors je vais faire
le pitch vous voulez que je fasse le
pitch qu'est-ce que c'est les pitchs
en Italie vous avez pas le ouais de quoi
vous avez pas le Pichu en Italie
vous continuez
[Applaudissements]
alors Charles de Poulignac donc est joué
par rue cap evrette grand Chambelland de
la jet-set parisienne débarquent à Ibiza
dans le domaine du roi des branchers
John John joué par José Garcia le plus
extravagant de tous les jets setters du
monde et il va chercher à gagner sa
confiance parce que il est plus rien il
est devenu plus rien et vous vous allez
l'aider à gagner la confiance de de
Johnson voilà parce que vous êtes une
vieille amie à lui vous vous retrouvez
etc
depuis toujours j'aime bien quand vous
parlez moi j'adore les filles quand
elles sont italiennes
c'est que José Garcia c'est le sosie de
George Michael c'est incroyable on
dirait vraiment George Michael je l'ai
pas vu George Michael puisqu'il voulait
pas que je sois là donc je l'ai pas
croisé c'est vrai qu'il voulait pas que
tu sois là George Michael pourquoi vous
avez peur de tomber amoureux
bien en marge de comprendre
depuis que j'ai regardé la ferme j'ai
beaucoup changé c'est pas mal de trucs
très drôles il y a les visites de la
maison ou même les chèvres prennent de
l'ecstasie
[Rires]
Anthony et ça marche non c'est vrai même
les chefs de l'ecstasie c'est vrai mais
oui tout le monde tout le monde
me fait hurler de rire c'est le centre
de rééducation où les people apprennent
à faire la queue c'est à dire qu'on
les gens attendent ils apprennent à
attendre
allez voir Jet 7 2 alias people
non on n'a pas déjà cadet
jacques a dit lever les bras là tu dois
lever les bras vas-y Jacadi lever les
bras ah ouais
il faut dire Jacadi si je dis pas
jacadies
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va bon alors on vous connaît
parce qu'on vous a vu beaucoup au cinéma
mais en fait on vous connaît pas très
bien on vous connaît pas très bien votre
vie vous êtes né à Rome hein à une date
qui est secrète moi je l'ai
non tu peux pas l'avoir c'est secret
votre vrai nom c'est Francesca
romanarielli je peux vous appeler
Francesca
bon alors père napolitain maire
estonienne c'est pour ça que vous avez
les yeux un peu capital de l'Estonie non
ah non
ça va ça va ça va
prendre les capitales donc père
napolitain maire estonienne et vos
parents avaient une relation assez
difficile c'était pas facile quand vous
étiez petit
votre père vous garde quand votre mère
s'en va
ils avaient une petite difficulté et
vous vous dites rien parce qu'à l'époque
les enfants disaient rien à l'époque les
enfants subissaient sans rien dire parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils disent
vous croyez pas
de les enfants des parents qu'ils ont
des problèmes
ils sont ils te changent les caractères
quoi peut-être après tu dis mais ça ça
veut rien dire de dire est-ce que tu
sens je pense qu'il y a une différence
ça vous a marqué vous
oui
alors en plus votre père meurt vous êtes
assez jeune à ce moment-là vous avez 12
ans donc une enfant ça c'est difficile
finalement
il y a pire quoi et depuis vous cherchez
toujours le père chez vos amours pour un
moment peut-être oui maintenant non non
c'est fini
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas faire une émission de cinéma
sur France 2
alors le premier film s'appelle et c'est
normal la femme la plus belle la Molière
et alors c'est terrible parce que pour
vous faire pleurer dans le film il vous
bat avec un avec un ceinturon mais qui
va dit tout ça
c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai oui c'est
c'est vous avez vu les traces pendant
deux ans
italienne ça c'est fini justement
j'espère on sait pas on sait pas on sait
jamais on sait jamais voilà en tout cas
j'aime quand vous dites ça
et donc à partir de là vous enchaînez
les tournages et toute votre toute votre
adolescence toute votre jeunesse se
passe à tourner finalement vous vous
avez pas le temps de vivre vous avez un
petit peu oublié de vivre non
mais ça c'est un peu
extrême quoi parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé mais les autres
ils allaient à l'école alors c'est une
autre façon d'être
occupé mais
j'ai sûrement vu ma vie j'espère mais
vous vous êtes amusés quand même le soir
après le tournage non non
tout de suite
de bons clients
Francesca grâce à cette carte vous
pouvez revenir quand vous voulez
tu as pas donné bon client je me suis
trompé
[Applaudissements]
je te dis non
je t'ai dit de donner une carte de bons
clients Laurent
[Applaudissements]
je propose pour se faire complètement
pardonner une pause bisous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on continue Laurent si tu permets
quand même donc la première fois qu'on
vous voit en France Frances cassé en 75
dans la dernière femme de Marco Ferreri
avec Gérard Depardieu mais vous devenez
une vedette vraiment internationale avec
Alain Delon dans mort d'un pourri de
Georges Lautner quoi je suis également
dans ce film t'es dans le film
non je fais un figurant on était à la
gare Montparnasse on s'est croisé toute
la journée et tu montais les marches moi
je la descendais et on est là tu n'avais
pas de soutien-gorge et tu m'as fait
passer une journée magnifique
et je t'en remercie
et dans le film de Ferreri rappelons
qu'elle coupe le sexe de Gérard
Depardieu avec un couteau électrique
quand même
voilà donc c'est un beau cadeau on y
pense jamais
on n'a pas le réflexe
voilà donc mort d'un pourri puis ensuite
de skeves dans les nouveaux monstres et
puis surtout moi le film de vous que je
préfère c'est quand de la folie
ordinaire qui est un film que j'adore là
vous mettez tout le monde d'accord dans
ce film voilà et alors c'est marrant
vous n'êtes jamais allé à Hollywood
[Rires]
qui n'est pas tout à fait prêt tout le
temps à faire non et moi à rester là
tout la vie oubliez tout moi je suis
[ __ ] européenne c'est pourquoi je
prends un cadeau mais
alors en France qui est très bizarre si
vous n'avez pas été tellement utilisé je
sais pas c'est pas à moi qui faut
demander ça alors ça commence un peu
maintenant avec la télévision vous avez
dans le compte de Monte-Cristo avec
Depardieu que vous y retrouver 22 ans
après a préféré rit le lion
de Londres 20 ans après Lautner non mais
c'est vrai
tu auras 45 ans
également les seconds rôles me dérangent
pas parce que de toute façon dans la
vraie vie on est déjà un premier rôle
c'est une très belle phrase
c'est vrai dans sa propre vie on est son
premier rôle
on s'entendrait bien tous les deux non
on a quelque chose à une complicité
entre nous oui
tu as envie de
[Applaudissements]
non je trouve que
Francesca ont vieillissant est devenu
très équilibré c'est ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est les effets une analyse
si j'ai fait analyse oui j'ai fait ça
vous a équilibré ça vous a fait du bien
équilibrer c'est un mot un peu difficile
à comprendre mais on cherche de s'aimer
quoi de trouver une harmonie dans soi
même c'est ça qui est après c'est utile
l'équilibre c'est un peu difficile à
savoir vous avez l'air très bien là
elle est insupportable et tout pas du
tout vous n'êtes pas du tout
insupportable
oui oui Catherine oui bien alors
équilibré aussi par le bouddhisme elle
body SMO non
il bouddhisme
[Rires]
c'est ça
te donne de l'énergie votre cerveau
ça se voit
j'espère cette prière donne de l'énergie
c'est vrai
ça monte
aussi pas monter ça ça dépend de chacun
tu peux faire un non je crois qu'elle
t'appelle
mais vous savez que en France il y a des
gens qui pensent que c'est une secte
quand même
tout ce qui en connaît pas tout ce qui
est
ce n'est pas ça fait c'est comme ça mais
c'est pas une secte pas du tout parce
qu'il y a un grand liberté il y a pas de
de
Claire il y a pas de prêtres il y a pas
quelque chose comme ça c'est tous on a
tous ensemble chacun fait non
gros
c'est un grand
par tout le monde comme un des grands
c'est déjà pas mal c'est l'essentiel
vous êtes pas obligé de prendre des
pilules comme tout le monde c'est mieux
c'est mieux que le Feng Shui mais
l'effectuer c'est notre chose
que je fais pour la cuisine c'est bien
je crois que vous pourriez beaucoup
m'apporter
je suis pas trop vieux pour vous
bien équilibré aussi par vos trois
enfants
la première c'est naïké qui est née
quand vous aviez 19 ans le père c'est
comme votre âge il est secret
le père de naïké il est secret
il est secret elle s'appelle naïc et il
est secret le père
elle a pas voulu donner un nom voilà
donc
c'est pas c'est tout non moi je sais qui
c'est mais
encore Sardou
mais c'est une thématique alors
incroyable
et alors likez un fait de vous une
grand-mère une très jolie grand-mère
d'ailleurs je dois dire quand on dit
qu'elle est grand-mère la petite fille
qui vient d'être maman il y a pas très
longtemps
l'enfant de Michael s'appelle Akash
ça veut dire quoi
voilà alors est-ce que depuis que vous
êtes grand-mère vous savez faire un bon
café
[Applaudissements]
c'est une référence à une pub française
tu peux pas comprendre parce que
franco-français
tous les femmes italiennes doivent faire
un bon café est-ce que depuis que vous
êtes grand-mère vous avez peur de la
canicule l'été
[Rires]
il fait chaud
il meurent mais je suis pas morte
la dernière était terrible de moi
avec les choses ça va très bien
est-ce que depuis que vous êtes grand
mère vous pensez la chirurgie esthétique
j'aurais pensé à ça même ça à être une
grammaire ça veut rien dire être
grammaire vous êtes bien ça va vous avez
pas besoin de chirurgie esthétique toute
façon aujourd'hui mais je sais pas
peut-être oui mais jusqu'à le moment que
je sens pas là nécessité je le fais pas
même si j'ai besoin peut-être que j'ai
besoin et je m'en fiche
de Francesca chirurgien esthétique comme
par hasard il y a l'appartement à
travers
une conception de la beauté et même même
si je suis pas 25 ans 27 ça va encore
bon alors voilà alors toute façon vous
voilà le problème avec vous je crois
qu'on peut le dire franchement je crois
que là on peut le dire les choses si on
a de la nuit vous avez besoin de vivre
avec un homme les histoires d'une nuit
comme ça ça vous plaît pas vous ce qu'il
faut c'est une relation suivie avec
vous avez vous avez déclaré l'orgasme
pour l'orgasme je m'en fiche oui moi
c'est pareil
je sais que toi non ça se voit tant que
ça
par exemple c'est différent
de ces décharger de quelques façons
ils sont plus
victime
il peut mettre certains choses à côté
du romantisme parce que présente un jour
c'était dans un pipe chaud par exemple
un jour plus
chaud si on regarde un film porno à la
télé vous dites après chaque fois je me
sens sale vous dites seul
c'est vrai ou pas
je sais pas moi j'aime pas j'aime vivre
certaines choses avec les cœurs c'est
terrible
il y a des gens qui aiment faire des
autres choses moi j'aime pas mais
chacun son truc moi je préfère les
femmes comme vous mais finalement je me
demande ce que vous êtes prêtes à faire
par amour pour un homme vous êtes prêtes
à faire beaucoup pour un homme oui oui
on va voir interview par amour
[Musique]
est-ce que
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous déguiser en
Elton John
oui avec les lunettes la perruque et
tout oui est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à prendre de la drogue
comme
mais non parce que j'ai je peux pas
aimer un homme qui me demande ça
est-ce que par amour si votre homme aime
les rubans les bottéros est-ce que vous
seriez prête à prendre 17 kg Botero
c'est 117
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser 100 fois les chaussettes sales
de votre mari ah ouais oui
c'est bien est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête par amour à accepter
quelques petites infidélités
et juste un peu non mais un peu non
pas pas de maîtresse tout ça non vous
êtes là par amour si ça le rend heureux
si vous l'aimez
un homme comme ça
avec la maîtresse pas d'accord pour
aller dans les clubs échangistes avec la
maîtresse rien à faire
même par amour mais non est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuel
ça dépend
de quoi si vous l'aimez vous demande de
devenir son esclave sexuel je trouve que
c'est un peu une interview stupide
[Applaudissements]
entièrement d'accord
en plus il y a des choses que l'on fait
c'est quelque chose que je sais pas pour
moi ça marche pas comme ça on y va
[Rires]
aussi peut-être
vous aimez bien un petit peu être
soumise quand même
décidé d'être quelque chose c'est une
chose alors ça c'est un autre type de
jeu
et c'est une chose consciente un jeu
consciente alors ça ça peut être aussi
drôle pour un moment mais
c'est moi que je décide d'accord quand
tu veux et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu